les gadgets technologiques sont toujours
parmi les cadeaux favoris sous le sapin
cette année nous les avons regroupés en
catégorie les gadgets techno pour se
divertir pour le télétravail nouvelles
tendances et pour prendre soin de soi
pascal forget un chroniqueur spécialisé
en technologies bon soit pascal bonsoir
je très content d'être ici
ben on est très contents de vous
accueillir de nouveau cette année on va
parler d'abord du divertissement vous
avez des suggestions pour nous on
commence avec le haut parleur aux modes
d'appauvrir parce que l'envahissement
des assistants personnels vocaux
n'arrête pas et apprendront à l'ancien
cette année le aux modes mini qui est un
haut parleur connectique qui est tout
petit qui permettent par la syrie donc
on peut lui dire 10 syrie et là je ne
répèterai pas pour pas que tous les gens
à la maison leur assistance active mais
on peut lui demander de jouer la musique
de son choix et étonnamment la grèce à
toute petite taille
le son est de qualité impressionnante
c'est vraiment impressionnant et de
l'analyse informatique est utilisé pour
détecter l'acoustique de la pièce en
temps réel et ajuste ils sont en
conséquence donc même si tout petit ça
sonne bien ça fonctionne
merveilleusement
l'inconvénient c'est qu'il faut avoir un
iphone ou un ipad pour activer le tout
donc si on n'est pas à prendre à la
maison c'est peut-être pas un très bon
choix
google pour sa caution de table c'est ça
le nez studio parce que google aussi a
décidé d'aller vers la qualité sonore la
mettre de l'avant parce qu'on s'est
rendu compte que beaucoup de gens
utilisaient leurs assistants personnels
pour diffuser de la musique beaucoup
donc le nest audio est plus puissant
plus performants sonne très bien que
c'est combien compatible avec un plus
grand nombre ces 129 dollars les deux
appareils et un conseil si vous avez
envie de vous lançant dépensez d'en
acheter 2 et de les connecter comme une
paire stéréo pour avoir un haut parleur
aux chiots par leurs droits les feuilles
très bien où dans l'avant dans plusieurs
pièces
donc ils peuvent tous jouer la musique
de façon uniforme partout on contrôler
le volume dans chaque pièce et c'est
merveilleux de passer d'une pièce à
l'autre et c'est la même musique qui
joue partout parlez nous du string bah
oui ça c'est une option pour ceux qui
ont gardé beaucoup de netflix et de télé
1 continue pendant le confinement
évidemment quand on a moins de choses à
faire on se divertit en regardant la
télé le streamer c'est pour améliorer la
qualité sonore de sa télévision et c'est
un appareil qui rompt soit compatible
avec tous les services de diffusion en
continu donc on écoute netflix 10 n'est
plus un peu plus il ya maintenant
plusieurs services qui permettent de
regarder des films et des séries télé
cette petite boîte leur permet de les
écouter tous ok en plus d'avoir une très
bonne qualité sonore ambiophonique ça
fait vraiment de belles différences pour
les dialogues dans les films il désire
n'a pas besoin d'être le volume ou si
élevé et on peut aussi ajuster le volume
pour que les dialogues sont amplifiées
mais que les explosions et les effets
sonores bruyant soit diminuée ça évite
de réveiller les enfants feraient si on
veut écouter la télé plus tard et vous
avez un casque de réalité virtuelle à
nous proposer aussi ça c'est oui c'est
la façon ultime de s'évader c'est pas la
première génération de casques de
réalité virtuelle qui existent mais le
oculus quest 2 c'est un produit de
facebook qui permet vraiment de s'évader
on enfile le casque et on se retrouve où
on veut dans le monde ont pu visiter des
musées voir des spectacles on peut joies
des jeux comme si on y était et même
faire de l'entraînement ou en un coach
virtuel devant soi dans un gymnase
magnifique
il ya ainsi un chiffre qui permet de
s'entraîner avec des glaciers autour de
soi sur un volcan
c'est féerique ça dépayse et c'est très
drôle de voir des spectacles sans avoir
à porter de masque ou non d'un casque
mais pas de masque
donc c'est très confortable et on peut
aussi même s'isoler dans sa bulle même
si le dow jones autour pour regarder par
exemple une série netflix comme si on
était dans une gigantesque salle de
cinéma même si on est dans une toute
petit appartement à montréal par exemple
la grosse tendance notamment dans les
petits appartements c'est le télétravail
présentement parlez nous du bureau
ajustable motorisés ic ir ou et ça c'est
quelque chose qui étaient en pénurie
depuis le début du confinement c'est un
table qui est ajustable automatiquement
en appuyant sur un bouton
c'est vraiment fantastique j'en utilise
une à la maison ça permet de travailler
assis un petit bout quand on veut on
peut se lève
et pour travailler faire des appels
vidéo cet extraordinaire de travailler
debout pour faire des affaires et des
appels vidéo soit on perd un peu la
concentration le fait d'être debout
c'est très stimulant et on appuie sur le
bouton on peut se remettre à un autre
niveau pour travailler peu importe la
taille de la personne qui travaille son
doigt et changer le bureau avec les
enfants ou avec un conjoint ou conjointe
des colocataires même vraiment vraiment
agréable et je vous tienne en stock il y
en a qui ont des auteurs programmables
donc il avoir la hauteur 1 2 3 et d'un
bouton à passer de l'un à l'autre comme
comme comme dans l'automobile finalement
le siège dans l'automobile sera peut
programmer à l'avancé
vous ne parlez d'un vélo avec une table
oui et ça c'est une autre chose que chez
nous il ya beaucoup de gens qui se sont
procuré des vélos d'entraînement et qui
après quelques temps ne s'en serve plus
à prendre la poussière dans un coin mais
si notre vélo d'entraînement est
combinée avec une table de travail
on voit ici dans le voyons comment dans
des bureaux il s'en sert exagéré
peut-être mais à la maison je suis
convaincu que ça - éviter de perdre deux
de gagner du poids pendant le
confinement parce que quand on peut pas
aller au gym on veut quand même
s'entraîner on s'installe on regarde une
série netflix on [ __ ] doucement en
même temps le niveau d'intensité est
ajustable donc on n'a pas besoin de
s'épuiser
c'est pas du gros caillou nécessairement
mais on peut pendant plusieurs minutes
plusieurs heures se motiver comme ça ça
permet de se déplacer de façon
sécuritaire
un second disque dur était virtuel en
plus cela on se déplace vraiment m'en
parlez nous des tendances pour prendre
soin de soi bracelet comme une montre en
c'est ça ouais c'est un bracelet
connecter l'appareil permet de tout
faire maintenant ça permet de mesurer à
la le l'oxygène dans le sang le rythme
cardiaque de détecter les arythmies le
bracelet sense 2 fitbit est compatible
avec plus d'appareils les appareils
android et sa détecte maintenant la
température corporelle ces espèces de
nouvelles tendances les caractéristiques
à rechercher sur les montres connecter
la température corporelle ce qui permet
après quelques jours d'observation de
nous dire si notre température un petit
peu changé
ça permettrait de détecter chez les
femmes le rythme le cycle menstruel ça
permettrait de voir son fait de la
fièvre peut-être
et ça permettrait peut-être avant même
parfois on se lève on sent un peu
patraque
on se dit qu'est ce qui se passe est ce
que ça va je vais quand même aller au
bureau mais si notre monde nous dit
qu'on a fait un peu de température pas
nécessairement beaucoup mais que notre
température monte par rapport à la
moyenne
en accumulant les données à long terme
ça permet d'avoir un diagnostic plus
rapide intéressant soit c'est chouette
parlez-nous d'un masque et techno ouais
ça c'est la surprise je l'essayé et je
vous assure se prend une bonne dose de
motivation pour la porter les masques on
sort on la copie contre la copie de
cette inconfortable celui là permet de
vivre son rêve de vivre comme un
astronaute
vous avez une forte oui à les ignorer
quand une fille fantastique je parle
comme le bonhomme carnaval wii ou julie
payette dans l'espace mais oui mais
voilà je peux pas supporter en la
présentant mais non je vais l'enlever
oui mais voilà parfait c'est fantastique
de deux ventilateurs à l'intérieur donc
ça permet d'éviter la but est de faire
circuler l'air de quatre filtres qui
empêche évidemment les particules
qu'ovide de s'infiltrer oui c'est ça
ahmed se protéger le visage en entier
quand je l'essayé dans un centre
d'achats c'était fantastique la réaction
des jeunes les gens étaient surpris les
gens me demander où est ce qu'on se
procure ce s'est pas donnée encore mais
je soupçonne que vous allez avoir
beaucoup de questions sur les comment se
procurer ce masque est là comment ça
s'appelle et un d'une compagnie qui
s'appelle mike rocktime est ok c'est sur
le web en ce moment c'est 300 dollars
américains c'est pas donné mais je
soupçonne que des masques similaires
vont probablement être faire bientôt
très confortable pour une longue période
pas de trucs évidemment pour se gratter
le nez c'est un peu plus compliqué c'est
pas très utile pour ça mais c'est utile
pour d'autres choses pascal merci
c'était passionnant comme d'habitude et
je vous souhaite de joyeuses fêtes
merci de vous